I want to ask you guys a question how
many languages do you speak this is not
a rhetorical question I actually want
you to think of a number some of you
it's pretty easy inside your head you're
like it's one you're speaking it buddy
I'm done others of you maybe you're
wondering if the language that an
ex-boyfriend or an ex-girlfriend taught
you what you learned all the cuss words
if it counts go ahead and count it be
nice to yourself when I ask myself the
question I came up with for arguably
five if I've been drinking quano Pallavi
no possible air italiano MA
but on closer examination I came up with
83 83 languages and I got tired and I
stopped counting and it forced me to
revisit this definition that we have of
language the first entry said the method
of human communication either spoken or
written consisting of the use of words
in a structured or conventional way the
definition that at the bottom refers to
specialized fields like medicine science
tech we know they have their own
vernacular or their own jargon but what
most interested me was that definition
right in the center there the system of
communication used by a particular
community or country and I'm not
interested in altering this definition
I'm interested in applying it to
everything we do because I believe that
we speak far more languages than we
realize and for the rest of our time
together I'm gonna attempt to speak in
one language that is native to every
single human being in this room but that
changes things a little bit because then
it's no longer a presentation it becomes
a conversation and in any conversation
there must be some sort of interaction
and for any interaction to happen there
has to be a degree of willingness on
both parties and I think if we just are
willing we will see the magic that can
happen with just a little bit of
willingness so I've chosen a relatively
low-risk common denominator that can
kind of gauge if we're all willing if
you're happy and you know it clap your
hands
para toda la gente que habla espanol por
favore commence AEDPA e menara una
persona sent Aloha qualcare la loi
commence our array Eve thank you so much
please be seated
now if that felt a little bit awkward I
promise there was no joke being had at
your expense I simply asked the
spanish-speaking audience to stand up
look at a person I was sitting close to
them and laugh and I know that that
wasn't nice and I'm sorry but in that
moment some of us felt something you see
we're often aware of what language does
when we speak somebody's language what
it does to connect what it does to bind
but we often forget what it does when
you can't speak that language what it
does to isolate what it does to exclude
and I want us to hold on as we journey
through kind of our a little walk of
languages hear me call my lawn
Manny a taro of toes Eva that I said in
Farsi I'd like to translate this idea of
taught off in the Persian culture which
really it has no equivalent in the
English lexicon the best definition
would be something like an extreme grace
or an extreme humility but that doesn't
quite get the job done so I'm gonna give
you an example if two gentlemen were
walking by each other it'd be very
common for the first one to look at the
other one and say Melissa town which
means I am indebted to you the other
gentleman would respond back chalk
editon which reads I opened my shirt for
you the first guy would respond back no
cata Tom which means I am your servant
and then the second guy would respond
back to him Hawke Izzy dupatta which
literally means I am the dirt beneath
your feet there's an exhibit for you
guys in case you did get the picture and
I share that with you because with new
languages come new concepts that didn't
exist before and the other thing is
sometimes we think language is about
understanding the meaning of a word but
I believe languages is about making a
word meaningful for yourself if I were
to flash this series of words on the
screen some of you you'd know exactly
what it is right away others of you you
might struggle a little bit
and I could probably draw a pretty
clear-cut line right around the age of
35 and older 35 and younger and for
those of us that are in the know we know
that's text speak or SMS language it's a
series of characters meant to convey the
most amount of meaning with the least
amount of characters which sounds pretty
similar to our definition of languages
system of communication used by a
community anyone who's ever gotten to a
argument via text can make a case for
how it's maybe not the best method of
communication but what if I told you
that what you saw earlier was a
modern-day love letter if you follow
along for the time being I love you lots
because you positively bring out all the
best in me and I laugh out loud in other
words let me know what's up because you
are a cutie in my opinion and as far as
I know to see you if you're not seeing
someone would make me happy for your
information I'll be right there forever
in any case keep in touch no response
necessary all my best wishes don't know
don't care if anyone sees this don't go
there see you later bye for now hugs and
kisses you only live what's kind of a
modern-day Romeo or Juliet in that
moment if you laughed you spoke another
language that needs no explanation
laughter it's one of the most common
languages in the world we don't have to
explain it to each other it's just
something we all feel and that's why
things like laughter and things like
music are so prevalent because they seem
to somehow transcend explanation and
convey a profound amount of meaning
every language we learn is a portal by
which we can access another language the
more you know the more you can speak and
it's something common that we all do we
take any new concept and we filter it
through an already existing access of
reality within us and that's why
languages are so so important because
they give us access to new worlds not
just people it's not just about seeing
or hearing it's about feeling
experiencing sharing and despite these
languages that we've covered I really
don't think we've covered one of the
most profound languages that there are
and that's the language of experience
that's why when you're talking with
someone if they've shared something that
you've shared you don't need to explain
it much
well that's why when you're sharing a
story and you finish and the people
you're talking to don't quite get it
the first thing we all say is guess you
have to be there I guess you had to be
here this week to know what this is
about it's kind of hard to explain isn't
it and for the sake of our research I'm
gonna close by asking that you
participate one more time in this
language of experience I'm gonna filter
through some languages and if I'm
speaking your language I'm gonna ask
that you just stand and you stay
standing you don't need to ask
permission just let me know that you see
me and I can also see you if you speak
this language of experience do you speak
this language when I was growing up in
primary school at the end of the year we
would have these parties and we vote on
whether we wanted to celebrate at an
amusement park
or a water park and I would really hope
the party wasn't not a water park
because then I'd have to be in a bathing
suit I don't know about you but
sometimes when I approach a dressing
room my sweat glands start activating on
their own because I know that garment is
not gonna look like it did on me like it
did on that mannequin or how about this
when I would go to family functions or
family gatherings every time I wanted a
second plate and I usually did it was a
whole exercise and cost-benefit analysis
my relatives looking at me like I don't
know you really need that looks like
you're doing okay there but do my cheeks
have a big pinch me sign that I didn't
see and if you're squirming or you're
laughing or you stood up you're
beginning to stand you're speaking the
language that I enduringly call a
language of growing up a fat kid and any
body image issue is a dialect of that
language I want you to stay standing
again if I'm speaking your language
please go ahead and stand imagine two
bills in my hand one is the phone bill
and one is the electric bill eeny meeny
miny moe pay one off let the other one
go which means I might not have enough
to pay both at the current moment you
got to be resourceful you got to figure
it out and if you're standing you know
the language of barely making ends meet
a financial struggle and if you've been
lucky enough to speak that language you
understand that there is no motivator of
greatness like deficiency not having
resources not having looks not having
finances can often be the barren soil
from which the most productive seeds are
painstakingly plowed and harvest when
asked if you speak this language the
second you recognize it feel free to
stand when we heard the diagnosis I
thought not that word anything but that
word I hate that word and then you ask a
series of questions are you sure has it
spread how long doctor how long and a
series of answers determines a person's
life and then my dad was hungry we'd all
rushed to the dinner table to eat
because that's what we did before we ate
together so we were gonna continue doing
that and I didn't understand why we were
losing this battle because I was taught
if you fight and you have the right
spirit you're supposed to win and we
weren't winning for any of you that
stood up you know very well that I'm
speaking the language of watching a
loved one battle cancer
any terminal illness is a derivative of
that language I'm going to speak one
last language oh no no I'm listening
yeah yeah yeah no no no no I mean you
right here yeah no I'm with you I'm with
you or imagine the lights are all off
and a blue light is just shining in your
face as you're laying on the bed and I
know some of you like me have dropped
that phone right on your face or this
one right passenger seat freaking out hi
can you watch the road
and for anybody that's stood up you
speak the language that I like to call
the language of disconnection
it's been called the language of
connection but I like to call it the
language of disconnection I don't mean
disconnection I mean this connection
human disconnection disconnected from
each other from where we are from our
own thoughts so we can occupy another
space if you're not standing you
probably know what it's like to feel
left out probably uh you know what it's
like when everybody's a part of
something
and you're not you know what it's like
being the minority and now that I'm
speaking your language I'm gonna ask you
to go ahead and stand since we're
speaking the same language because I
believe that language of being the
minority is one of the most important
languages you can ever speak in your
life because how you feel in that
position of compromise will directly
determine how you act in that position
of power thank you for participating if
you take a seat I want to speak one last
language this one you don't need to
stand I just want to see if you
recognize it most of girls in the world
are complaining about it most the poems
in the world been written about it
most the music on the radio will be
hitting about it kickin about it or
ripping about it most verses in the game
people spittin about it most the songs
in the world people talking about it
most of broken hearts I know are walking
without it started to doubt it or lost
without it
most the shadows in the dark have
forgotten about it everybody in the
world would be tripping without it every
boy and every girl would be dead without
it struggle without nothing without it
most the pages that are filled are
filled about it the tears that are
spilled spilled about it the people that
I felt it are real about it a life
without it you'd be lost when I'm in in
and I feel it I'd be shouting about it
everybody in the whole world knowing
about it I'm hurting wrote down and be
flowing about it going about it wrong
cuz I didn't allow it can the wound or
scar heal without it can't the way that
you feel be concealed about it everybody
has their own ideal about it dream about
it appeal about it so what's the deal
about it now you bout it to know that
life is a dream and unreal without it
but I'm just a writer
what can I reveal about it why is it
that the most spoken about language in
the world is the one we have the
toughest I'm speaking or expressing no
matter how many books how many seminars
how many life coaching sessions we go to
we just can't get enough of it and I ask
you now is that number that you had at
the beginning has that changed
and I challenge you when you see someone
to ask yourself what languages do we
share and if you don't come up with
anything ask yourself what languages
could we share and if you still don't
come up with anything ask yourself what
languages can I learn and no matter how
inconsequential or insignificant that
conversation seems at the moment I
promise you it will serve you in the
future
my name is poet Ali thank you
[Applause]